elles ont fait le tour du monde les
images de l'atterrissage du rover
persévérance sur la planète mars
ce robot piloté par la nasa est un
concentré de technologie c'est le cas de
l'instrument super cannes fabriqués en
france
sa caméra prochainement en service a été
produite par trois des plus une
entreprise située dans les yvelines
elles permettent surtout d'orienter le
laser pour savoir où le lazare sera en
train de tirer ce qui va créer une
poussière de la roche qui va être
pulvérisé par le laser et puis les
images ont été récupérés par la caméra
et permettre d'analyser quelles sont les
éléments qui sont à l'intérieur de cette
poussière amélioration de la qualité de
l'image de la performance des composants
électroniques 3d plus est spécialisé
dans la production de ces technologies
satellites de télécommunication
d'observation ou rover depuis 1995 cette
société consacre 90 % de son activité à
l'industrie spatiale persévérance pour
nous c'est pas une nouveauté dans la
mesure où on était déjà sur le rover
précédent qui s'appelait curiosity
l'enjeu pour nous c'est mettre à la
disposition des scientifiques nos
meilleurs savoir-faire pour qu'ils
puissent avoir l'instrument dont il rêve
pour essayer de découvrir l'origine de
la vie sur mars
ça permet de tirer nos technologies vers
le meilleur de ce qu'on peut faire et
puis après les autres produits plus plus
classique je dirais vous envoie en
bénéficier dans les prochaines semaines
persévérance va commencer à utiliser
cette caméra fabriqués à buc 3d + a déjà
en ligne de mire la prochaine étape de
cette mission martienne
ils vont collecter des échantillons et
donc faudra les ramener sur terre donc
ça c'est deux ou trois missions les deux
ou trois missions suivantes voilà qui
commence à être en préparation
et puis par ailleurs non à d'autres
activités non plus classique 1 sur des
satellites d'observation de la terre
pour la météo la surveillance du climat
ou des choses comme ça 270 salariés
travaillent au sein de cette entreprise
elle réalise 70 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires